the memo is out and we are going to go
through it as it comes out more it's
coming out piece by piece but well we'll
do what we can
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
yes one of the dangers of doing a live
show is that news breaks right as you
are doing the show so the full memo is
not yet out we have only seen summaries
of a memo which is itself a summary of
intelligence documents so we'll bring
you all of the information as it breaks
but we have some interesting interesting
news about the memo and it's not exactly
a nothing burger there's a lot of talk
about how it was going to be a giant
disappointment gave what by over in New
York at the Washington Examiner says
it's true if what Fox News is reporting
is true if the memo itself is reflective
of truth then the FBI has some answers
that it needs to be giving we will talk
about all of that in just one second
first I want to say thank you to our
friends over at Dollar Shave Club so
while you were waiting for this show to
start you grew a beard because we were a
little bit late well that means that you
need my friends over at Dollar Shave
Club to help you out
you've heard me talk about the amazing
products at Dollar Shave Club they don't
just have their magical razors they also
have their dr. Carver's shea butter and
right now they have everything else
right body cleanser hair gel and yes
even the fabled butt wipes they have you
covered head to toe now it's a great
time to give Dollar Shave Club a try you
get your first month of their best razor
along with travel sized version of
shaved butter body cleanser and yes even
the magical but webs for just $5 after
that replacement cartridges ship for
just a few dollars a month this is the
DSC starter set so get yours right now
five bucks exclusively at
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash been use that
slash pen so they know that we sent you
and all of their products are fantastic
you will feel cleaner you will smell
better people will love you more you'll
have a happier life dollarshaveclub.com
slash been using that slash been against
and know that you sent you and also so
you get that special deal for their
travel kit for five bucks and then
replacement cartridges after that for
just a few dollars a month all right so
we do not have the entire memo the
entire memo is about to be released but
we don't actually have the entire text
of the memo if it comes out during the
show then I will just read the entire
memo to you verbatim because not that
long it's about four pages long so here
is what we know according to Fox News
the memo suggests that the FBI when it
first gathered a FISA warrant on on
Carter page Carter page was a from a
foreign policy adviser and he was
supposedly colluding with the Russians
right this was the supposition of the
FBI this is why they went and got a FISA
Warren
an American citizen who was a member of
the Trump campaign the question is what
was that warrant based on when he
submitted applications and FISA courts
you have to say here's why we have
probable cause to believe that we need a
wiretap on this guy so what did they use
for that well according to the according
to the memo the only thing that they
used and the central component that they
used was the steel dossier the steel
dossier was a piece of bad research
compiled by a spy named Christopher
Steele who went over to Russia and
talked to probably some paid Russian
folks and it was done on behalf of
fusion GPS using GPS and Apple research
firm originally fusion GPS and was hired
by the Washington free beacon to do
Apple research on Trump they cut out of
that project but then fusion gps shopped
around that Intel and Hillary Clinton
decided that she was going to fund the
Oppo research file so she funded the
fusion GPS dossier which was based on
research from Christopher Steele who was
getting information from the Russians
that information was then funneled to
the FBI and the FBI based on that
unverified dossier based on their a
piece of information that were unwilling
to verify went to the FISA courts now
why is that a big deal it's a big deal
for a couple of reasons it's a big deal
for a couple of reasons number one the
Fox News is called Fox News is quoting
from the memo they're the only people
have access is Washington Examiner and
Fox News at this point according to Fox
News
Christopher Steele look I could compiled
the memo the original dossier that the
warrant was based on admitted his
feelings against then-candidate Trump in
September of 2016 when he said that
Steele was quote desperate that
president from not get elected and was
passionate about him not being president
but that's not the only thing that's in
the memo according to to the Washington
Examiner calling Byron New York at the
Washington Examiner the steel dossier
formed an essential part of the initial
in all three renewal FISA applications
against Kyra page here is the key point
Andrew McCabe the deputy FBI director
who just resigned confirmed that no FISA
warrant would have been sought from the
FISA Court without the Steele dossier
information in other words they used as
the centerpiece of getting a warrant on
an American citizen who was part of the
Trump campaign and Oppo research hit
from Hillary Clinton that was non
verified what's even worse the political
origins of the steel dossier were known
to senior DOJ and FBI officials but
excluded from FISA applications so by
omission they lied to the court
they went to the FISA Court and they
said we have information that all this
stuff is happening with regard to Carter
page but they didn't say we got this
from a fusion GPS dossier compiled by
Hillary Clinton because then the court
might have said well have you checked
any of this then the court might have
thought well have you checked into this
and this raises some serious questions
by the way about the operations of FISA
courts if they're not actually doing the
research and asking the FBI to verify
that the information they're being
provided is actually true if they're
just putting things like the Russian P
tape remember the dossier was filled
with a bunch of bad information like the
idea that Trump had gone to Moscow and
then hired a hotel he tried to get the
room that Barack Obama Michelle Obama
had stayed and then hired Russian
prostitutes to pee on the bed you recall
this it was most of the stuff was
nonsense and nearly none of it has been
verified if they were using that
unverified information to get a FISA
wards and the FISA Court went along with
that without asking any other questions
that had some broader questions about
how far the courts are actually putting
out the warrants apparently DOJ official
Bruce or met with Steele beginning in
the summer of 2016 and that's when
Steele told him that he wanted Trump not
to be President the FBI and Justice
Department is all according to
Washington Examiner bomber New York the
FBI and Justice Department mounted a
month-long effort to keep the
information outlined in the memo out of
the house intelligence committees hands
only the threat of contempt charges and
other forms of pressure forced the FBI
and Justice to give up the material once
Intelligence Committee leaders and staff
compiled some of that information into
the memo the FBI and Justice Department
supported by Capitol Hill Democrats
mounted a ferocious campaign of
opposition saying release of the memo
would endanger national security in the
rule of law now if what these excerpts
show is what's really the main point of
the memo I don't know how that
endangered national security or the rule
of law that looks like that was a cover
if that's the case by the FBI and by
Democrats because they didn't want the
information getting out there
Intelligence Committee Chairman Devin
Union was determined to make the
information available to the public and
President Trump of course cleared it
just today and sent it over to the house
now I'm rapidly updating my Twitter to
see if there they're actually releasing
the full text at this point they've only
released excerpts so far so we have not
actually seen the the full thing we're
also going to find out whether there is
whether there's a democratic response to
the memo right we're going to find out
what the Democratic response had to say
because they're of course saying that
all of this is taken out of context I
would like to hear how this is taken out
of context or how this was gotten wrong
so again Fox News Washington Examiner
are basically accusing the FBI of the
same thing and accusing the DOJ of the
same thing and that is essentially
colluding with the Hillary Clinton
campaign who in essence were working
with a source who's relying on the
Russians for information about Donald
Trump and then they were taking that
information to open a FISA warrant on
Carter page so if this is the
centerpiece what does that mean what
does that mean well it could mean one of
two things it could mean that the entire
Trump Russia collusion thing was based
on a lie put out by the Hillary Clinton
campaign or bad info put out by the
Hillary Clinton campaign and therefore
fruit of the poisonous tree the entire
Russian collusion scandal was a bunch of
nonsense from the very beginning and
that this entire investigation has been
a sham and a fraud perpetrated at the
highest levels of the American
government by the Obama administration
the Hillary Clinton campaign the DOJ and
the FBI right that is observation number
one or it could be that after the FISA
warrant was actually gotten on Carter
page it turns out there was other
information that came up and that other
information lent credibility to the idea
that there was some sort of collusion
going on like for example the Donald
Trump jr. meeting in Trump Tower with a
Russian lawyer the letters between
Donald Trump jr. the emails between
Donald Trump jr. and a Russian PR guy
saying that the Russian government was
trying to help out Donald Trump jr. it
does cast a new light on a lot of this
idiot it makes some of the conspiracy
theories about meetings like that a
little bit more I would say easy to
swallow and one of the conspiracy
theories of that fusion GPS which was
working with the Russian lawyers who
were who were meeting with Donald Trump
jr. that fusion GPS set this up as sort
of a sting operation I always thought
that was a bit exaggerated didn't maybe
it's not exaggerated as much as I
thought so all of this could be an
excuse for Donald Trump's start firing
people it is quite possible that Donald
Trump just starts firing people that he
ends the Muller investigation on the
back of this and that the the President
of the United States litt says listen
this whole thing was tainted from the
very beginning noting that the
investigation comes up with can be true
because originally this is based on bad
information from Hillary we don't know
the extent to which the DOJ and the FBI
were colluding with the Hillary Clinton
campaign to get Donald Trump during the
campaign and in their form in a fire
everybody I think that it's gonna take a
few more steps to get there so Paul Ryan
was
yesterday he of course has seen the memo
already had been circulated in the house
he says that the memo is filled with
some bad stuff but that doesn't mean the
mother should be fired or abused then
that needs to come to light so that that
doesn't happen again
what this is not is an indictment on our
institutions of our justice system this
memo is not indictment of the FBI of the
Department of Justice it does not impugn
the Moller investigation or the Deputy
Attorney General what it is is the
Congress's legitimate function of
oversight to make sure that the FISA
process is being used correctly and that
if it wasn't being used correctly that
needs to come to light and people need
to be held accountable so that we do not
have problems in the again because this
does infect our civil liberties okay so
does Trump now fire everyone this
permanent fire everyone that's the big
question that's going to be asked next
and we will get to that in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at legacy box so you're
it's coming up on Valentine's Day you
know Mother's Day and Father's Day are
coming up relatively soon actually and
now it's time for you to start getting
gifts for family members one of the best
gets you can get for a family member is
ensuring that all of your photos videos
old films all of that is available to
watch and access at anytime and that's
what legacy box is for right now you can
look at all of your photos and your
videos on your phone but if you have
anything old you have stuff in the
garage she's been sitting there
moldering for years well now you can
have legacy box legacy watches you go
all that stuff you put it in a box you
send it to our folks at legacy box comm
and they take all of those outdated
formats camcorder VHS tapes super 8 film
old photos and they convert them into
perfectly preserved digital files so
again you load it up with all your old
tapes films pictures they have stickers
they put on each piece so you can trace
where it is in the process and we've
used it in the Shapiro household it's
just fantastic it saves you lots of time
it actually saves you money because you
don't have to schlep that stuff to to
some conversion facility over 350,000
families have trusted legacy box to
preserve countless irreplaceable
memories make 2018 the year that you
preserve those memories you have it
available on thumb drive or DVD so you
can always take a look at it for a
limited time right now you can say 40%
at legacy box comm 40% at legacy box
comm slash Ben get started right now for
45 bucks
right
now at Legacy voxcom / Ben that's their
cheapest package legacy box comm / Ben
again this is just a wonderful wonderful
service I think that there's there's not
much that you can do that's going to be
better for the better for your family
then than this I think that if you if
you do this service it's gonna make your
life better and your family's life
better I think preserving these memories
is really crucial so legacy box comm
select Ben for 40% off and their
packages start at just $45 okay so so
president Trump in responding to the
release of the memo and and here is what
he had to say the memo was sent to
Congress it was Declassified Congress
will do whatever they're going to do but
I think it's a disgrace what's happening
in our country and when you look at that
and you see that and some of the other
things what's going on a lot of people
should be ashamed of themselves and much
worse than that so I sent it over to
Congress and they will do what they are
going to do whatever they do is find it
was Declassified and let's see what
happens but a lot of people should be
ashamed thank you very much okay so you
know the president was also asked about
what should happen to the should happen
to rod Rosenstein who's the Deputy
Attorney General who was working in the
in in the in the DOJ at the time that
all this happened and and he said that
he had no answers on that that he was
not going to talk about what would
happen in rod Rosenstein so the real
question here is now does Trump start
firing everybody saying the entire thing
was a ruse from the beginning now as I
say it there now we're down to two
possibilities right we're down to two
possibilities one is if the memo is
accurate and if it is not exaggerated if
it's not taken out of context if it's
not lying we haven't seen any of the
underlying applications or materials
which Trump could declassify but has not
if let's say that that was the
centerpiece of Trump Russia collusion
that's all they had was this FISA
warrant on Carter page and this Russian
dossier that in essence all this is
gonna come down to is the dossier then I
think Trump has an excuse to say listen
we're done here okay there's nothing
happening here there's nothing for me to
obstruct I've been saying all along I'm
innocent and for me to just go to James
Comey and say why don't you say I'm
innocent James Comey wouldn't do it and
so I fired him that's not obstruction of
justice because I'm innocent there's
nothing for me to obstruct I'm not
destroying documents I'm not going out
of my way to shut down an investigation
there literally is nothing here and this
memo shows there's nothing here
question that that's possibility number
one possibility number two is a little
bit different and that is as I've said
there's other information that there's
other information that suggests that the
Trump Russia collusion thing is real
right again that that Donald Trump jr.
meeting at the at the Trump Tower or
maybe there's information that we
haven't heard about yet so we'll find
out in short order because the Democrats
I'm sure will respond to this the FBI
will start leaking materials and we'll
find out whether Devin Nunez memo is
just partisan hackery on behalf of the
Trump administration in order to shut
down the Malheur investigation or
whether it is something else entirely
okay but but bottom line is here's what
it looks like Barack Obama's DOJ spied
on his political opponent that's that's
really what it looks like here now Chuck
Todd is complaining because so far we've
only seen excerpts and those excerpts
have been leaked to from the media
outlets like the Washington Examiner and
Fox News I'm desperately trying to load
the memo right now and it's crashed the
House website because our government
sucks at everything so they can't even
put up a damn memo so we can actually
read the memo but when people run around
this weekend with their hair on fire I
think there's a reason for people to run
around again this opens up a whole can
of worms why did the FBI and DOJ try to
hide this from Congress number one they
were subpoenaed in order to get this
material why did they hide it from
Congress number two why were Democrats
trying to shut down the memo what
exactly I assume they'll come out today
and talk about which parts of this were
out of context but we haven't heard
exactly what was out of context yet if
nothing was out of context this is
really bad number three and what other
information if any was use to get that
five more on time Carter page I said
they're just a bunch of questions that
are unanswered here and the reason that
I'm hesitating is because I really don't
want to I really don't want to say
anything out of line about what exactly
has happened so here here it is okay so
finally we are now we are now getting
this to load it's really hard to do this
in real time when the when the house
website is down we're trying to load
desperately the actual memo so I can
read the text of it to you okay so here
it is purpose this memorandum provides
members an update on significant facts
relating to the committee's ongoing
investigation into the Department of
Justice and Federal Bureau of
Investigation and their use of foreign
intelligence surveillance act during the
2016 presidential election cycle our
findings which are detailed below raise
concerns with the legitimacy and
legality of certain DOJ and FBI
interactions with the FISA Court and
represent a troubling breakdown of legal
is established to protect the American
people from abuse is related to the FISA
process so now they they go right into
it on October 21st 2016 the DOJ and FBI
sought and received a FISA probable
cause order authorizing electronic
surveillance on Carter page from the
FISA Court pages a US citizen who served
as volunteer adviser to the Trump
presidential campaign consistent with
requirements under FISA the application
first had to be certified by the
director or deputy director of the FBI
and then required the approval of the
Attorney General Deputy Attorney General
that I've been rod Rosenstein or the
Senate controlled confirmed the
assistant attorney general for the
National Security Division the FBI and
DOJ obtained one initial FISA warrant
targeting Carter page and three fives of
renewals from the FI FIS see that's the
FISA Court as required by statute a FISA
order on an American citizen must be
renewed by the FISA Court every 90 days
and each renewal requires a separate
finding of probable cause then director
James Comey signed three FISA
applications in question on behalf of
the FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe
signed one then da da Jie that's a
director the Deputy Attorney General
Sally Yates and then Acting Deputy
Attorney General attainable Entei and
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
each signed one or more five say
applications on behalf of the DOJ due to
the sensitive nature of foreign
intelligence activity FISA submissions
including renewals before the FISC are
classified as such the public's
confidence in the integrity of the FISA
process depends on the courts ability to
hold the government to the highest
standard particularly as it relates to
the surveillance of American citizens
however the courts rigor in protecting
the rights of Americans reinforced by
90-day renewals of surveillance orders
is necessarily dependent on the
government's production to the court of
all material and relevant facts this
should include information potentially
favorable to the target of the FISA
application that is known by the
government in the case of Carter page
the government had at least four
independent opportunities before the
court to accurately provide an
accounting of the relevant facts however
our findings indicate that as described
below material and relevant information
was emitted okay so what they're saying
is that the FBI and the DOJ essentially
lied by omission to the FISA Court okay
number one the dossier compiled by
Christopher steel the steel dossier on
behalf of the Democratic National
Committee and the Hillary Clinton
campaign formed an essential part of the
Carter page 5s application steel was a
longtime FBI source who was paid over
$160,000 by
DNC and Clinton campaign bein lawfirm
perkins coie and research firm fusion
gps to obtain derogatory information on
donald trump's ties to russia
neither the initial application in
october 2016
nor any of the renewals disclosed or
reference the role of the DNC clinton
campaign or any party or campaign in
funding steele efforts even though the
political origins of the steel dossier
were then known to senior DOJ and FBI
officials the initial FISA application
notes Steele was working for a named us
person but does not name fusion GPS or
principal Glenn Simpson who was paid by
US law firm representing the DNC even
though that was known by the DOJ at the
time the application does not mention
steel was ultimately working on behalf
of them and paid for by the DNC and
Clinton campaign or the FBI had
separately authorized payments to steel
for the same information so that's the
big point here right is that the the
dossier was the basis for the FISA
warrant and that was the basis for
launching the entire investigation to
the Carter page FISA application also
cited extensively a September 23rd 2016
Yahoo News article by Michael Isikoff
which focuses on pages July 2016 trip to
Moscow this article does not corroborate
the steel dossier because it is derived
from information leaked by Steele
himself to Yahoo News the page FISA
application incorrectly assesses that
still did not directly provide
information to Yahoo News Steel has
admitted in British Court filings he met
with Yahoo News and several other
outlets in September 2016 at the
direction of fusion gps perkins coie was
aware of Steele's initial media context
because they hosted at least one meeting
in washington DC in 2016 with steel
infusion gps where this matter was
discussed so they're knocking down the
assumption that there was other
information used for the carter page
warrant right because the carter page
application originally included this
yahoo news article by Michael Isikoff
but that was coming from the same place
namely Christopher steel steel was
suspended and then terminated as an FBI
source for what the FBI defines the most
serious of violations an unauthorized
disclosure to the media of his
relationship with the FBI then on
October 30th 2016 Mother Jones article
by David corn Steele should have been
terminated for his previous undisclosed
contact with Yahoo and other outlets in
September before the FISA application
before the was it before the page
application was sent to the court in
October but still improperly concealed
from and lied to the FBI about those
contacts so they're now suggesting when
Steele should be prosecuted for lying to
the FBI
Steele's numerous encounters with the
media by
the cardinal rule of source handling
maintaining confidentiality and
demonstrated that steel had become a
less than reliable source for the FBI
before and after steel was terminated as
a source he maintained contact with the
DOJ via then associate Deputy Attorney
General Bruce or a senior DOJ official
who works closely with Deputy Attorneys
General y 8m later Rosenstein shortly
after the election the FBI began
interviewing or documenting his
communications with steel for example in
September 2016 I'm reading directly from
this fabled four page memo put out by
Devin Nunes Steele admitted to or his
feelings against then-candidate Trump
when Steele said he was quote desperate
that Donald Trump not get elected and
was passionate about him about not being
president now there she waits to read
that one Steele thought that Trump was
actually in bed with the Russians and
didn't want him to be President or two
he hated Trump and therefore trumped up
all this stuff against Trump this clear
evidence of Steele's bias was recorded
by or at the time and subsequently an
official FBI files been not reflected in
any of the page FISA applications during
the same period or his wife this is a
Deputy Attorney General was employed by
fusion GPS to assist in the cultivation
of opposition research on Trump or later
provided the FBI with all of his wife's
Apple research paid for by the DNC and
Clinton campaign via effusion GPS the
Orr's relationship with steel and fusion
gps was inexplicably concealed from the
FISA Court so all of this smells
terrible all of this is super super
dirty stuff and in just a second we're
going to go through the rest of the memo
and we're gonna get Trump's reaction to
all of this it sounds like he's
preparing for mass firings so things are
about to heat up in a serious way we'll
get to all of that in just one second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at helix sleep so if
you're losing sleep lately then you may
need to catch up over the weekend
because let's face it this is going to
light up Twitter and Facebook and the
media for the rest of the day you're
gonna need some sleep over the weekend
that's why you need the best mattress
and that's what helix sleep does for you
of a helix sleep mattress in our bedroom
it is spectacular it is more comfortable
than any other mattress I've ever slept
on I can say that honestly certainly
helix leap offers something that exists
nowhere else a mattress
personally personalized to your unique
preferences and sleeping style that will
not set you back thousands of dollars
you go to helix sleep calm / Ben you
take a two to three minutes sleep quiz
they'll build you a custom mattress it's
the best thing you've ever slept on for
couples they'll even personalize each
side of mattress if you want everyone
from GQ to Cosmopolitan to the show
raving about helix mattress in it
arrives to wreak
your door in a week you pop up in the
box inflates right in front of you you
try it for 100 nights and if you don't
love it they will pick it up and refund
you info go to helix sleep calm slash
been right now and you get 50 bucks
toward your custom mattress that's helix
sleep comm slash been again helix sleep
comm slash been for 50 bucks off your
order
again helix sleep calm /ban use the
slash bends that they know that we say
you as well fifty bucks off an already
inexpensive mattress that sleeps as well
as any mattress on the market helix
sleep comm slash been check it out right
now okay back to back to the steel
dossier memo back to the Stefan Nunez
memo that is that is blowing up the
internet right now it actually shut down
the government website so here's what it
says so we've already established
according to this memo a couple of
things one we have established that the
FISA warrant originally taken out on
Trump campaign member Carter page was
taken out based on a dossier compiled by
Christopher Steele on behalf of the DNC
that information was never revealed to
the FISA Court there was apparently no
other confirming information that was
used we also know now that Steele had an
agenda against Trump and openly admitted
such and that he worked with the Deputy
Attorney General whose wife was busy
compiling this information on behalf of
the DNC and the Hillary campaign for
fusion GPS the memo continues according
to the head of the FBI's
counterintelligence division assistant
director Bill pre step corroboration of
the steel dossier was in its infancy at
the time of the initial fit page FISA
application after Steele was terminated
a source validation report conducted by
an independent unit within FBI assess
seals reporting has only minimally
corroborated in early 2017 director
Comey briefed the president elect Trump
on a summary of the steel dossier even
though it was according to his June 2017
testimony salacious and unverified while
the FISA application relied on Steele's
past record of credible reporting on
other unrelated matters it ignored or
concealed his anti-trump financial and
ideological motivations furthermore
Deputy Director McCabe testified before
the committee in December 2017 that no
surveillance warrant would have been
sought from the FISA Court without the
steal dossier information so that's an
amazing admission by McCabe that the
steel dossier was the only thing that
allowed this investigation to start and
then we conclude the FISA the page FISA
application also mentions information
regarding fellow Trump campaign adviser
George papadopolis but there is no
evidence of any cooperation or
conspiracy between page and Papadopoulos
the Papadopoulos information triggering
the opening of an FBI
counterintelligence in vest
in late july 2016 by FBI agent Peter
struck struck was reassigned by the
special counsels office to FBI Human
Resources for improper text messages
with his mistress FBI attorney Lisa page
no known relation to Carter page where
they both demonstrated a clear bias
against Trump and in favor of Clinton
whom struck had also investigated the
struck Lisa page texts also reflect
extensive discussions about the
investigations orchestrating leaks to
the media and include a meeting with
deputy director McCabe to discuss an
insurance policy against president
Trump's election okay that is the end of
the memo so the bottom line is if you
think that the newness memo covers
everything I mean this is my sure I'm
reading this in real time so here's my
real-time tank if you think that the
Nunez memo is the completion is the is
the entirety of all of the information
in the trump Kalu Russia collusion case
then the whole thing is not only a empty
vessel it is a sting operation by the
Clinton operation working in cahoots
with the FBI and the DOJ if there is
nothing else there if they can show
nothing else there and all this
obstruction stuff all of this Trump
firing Comey all of this Trump asking
Rosen seeing whose side he was on all of
this seems to fall by the wayside
because let's face it if there's nothing
there and Trump is saying there's
nothing there why won't you guys side
with me that's not the same thing as him
attempting to obstruct justice
so the memo is in fact a bombshell it's
there there is a you know there is
something there that that is shocking
and also by the way the idea that the
idea that the memo in terms of national
security which is what Democrats have
been proclaiming has been pretty much
blown out of the water now that we've
seen the memo there's nothing there by
the way that we hadn't already supposed
when I was asked about why it wasn't
when I talked on the show about why the
memo what the memo said I speculated the
memo said exactly that's right if you go
back and listen to the shows I
speculated I didn't read the memo then
what the memo said was this this was the
center of the memo
and I said if that's the case how does
this endanger national security and yet
the Democrats were out there saying this
over and over and over like Jeff Merkley
the senator from Oregon he came out and
he said that if the memo were at least
the Intel community would stop talking
with the house it also goes to the heart
of the manipulation of very sensitive
national secrets highly classified
information that is given to the
Intelligence Committee with the
understanding it will not be released in
an
fashion that in in dangers the United
States or in a fashion that manipulates
the information for political purposes
and so that that understanding goes to
the heart of how the committee is able
to get sensitive information in the
first place why why the government's
willing to share it with the committee
so this really threatens to blow up the
whole contract between the branches of
government over sensitive information
okay it's just ridiculous that that this
was the suggestion first of all the
Congress oversees this agency this is
not how government works can the
intelligence commit and the intelligence
community doesn't get to tell Congress
to sniff itself the intelligence
community is run by Congress rent
Congress has oversight power over them
so the idea that the intelligence
committee will stop sharing is
ridiculous James Comey tweeted this
yesterday what an insufferable character
he's turned out to be here's what James
Comey tweeted yesterday saying we should
appreciate the FBI speaking up I wish
more of our leaders would but take note
American history also shows that in the
long run weasels and Liars never hold
the field so long as good people stand
up not a lot of schools or streets named
for Joe McCarthy so this isn't about Joe
McCarthy at this point this is about you
oversaw an FBI that was seeking FISA
warrants against American citizens based
on shoddy intelligence and you refused
to even turn over that information to
the FISA Court they couldn't even go
they couldn't even do this I mean this
is this is insane
speaking of insanity no members of the
media al Sharpton Chris Matthews they're
saying that this turns the Constitution
on his but rather this this kills the
Constitution it kills the Constitution
for the President of the United States
to declassify material inside the
executive branch like they don't
understand the Constitution here's Chris
Matthews over an M&E state making that
case all right Lee CCG up come on show
coming here misunderstand the
constitution to make a lot of money ah
go but a constitutional crisis somebody
it seems to me the Constitution has
always been turned on its butt we've got
a Congress a chairman of a committee on
intelligence which has historically been
a bipartisan committee and usually even
remembered members and they're basically
there to work together and to try to
find out if our intelligence committees
are doing their job and it's been turned
into a tool of a president playing
defense okay again turn into a tool the
president playing defense that's out I'm
seeing from the memo so we'll have to
see what the response is from Democrats
we'll have to see if they can bring
forward more information again the memo
doesn't answer everything it doesn't
answer why the Donald Trump jr. meeting
happened why he was showing willingness
to collude with the
it doesn't show why George papadopolis
was lying to the FBI it doesn't cover
everything but it raises some pretty
serious questions about how the FISA
Court does its business and whether the
FBI and DOJ were lying in order to gain
a FISA warrant and whether they have an
agenda against Trump now again does that
necessarily kill them all our
investigation probably not but it does
set some pretty rigorous questions in
front of particularly Deputy Attorney
General Rosenstein who went forward with
these FISA applications if all they were
but remember Carter page has not been
indicted right when and when knew all
these indictments were about to come
down my understanding my thought was
that it was going to be Paul manna fort
and Mike Flynn and Carter page there's
been no indictment of Carter page so as
far as we know Carter page was not
involved in criminal activity he's just
an idiot who wanders around Russia
looking for cash right doesn't actually
mean that Carter page was a criminal so
that means that you launched this entire
investigation on the back of it the only
guy who hasn't been indicted that we
thought would be indicted the man of 14
citement by the way has nothing to do
with the Trump campaign the man for
tonight Minh has to do with him lying to
the FBI the george papadapolis
indictment is the only one that has to
do with the Trump campaign because he
apparently lied to the FBI about
meetings that he had in London with a
Russian cutout but it's not clear that
Papadopoulos was working on behalf of
the Trump administration or the Trump
campaign Trump campaign basically
disowned Papadopoulos in the middle of
the campaign so all of this calls into
serious question the entire
investigation doesn't mean the
investigation that should be killed
doesn't mean that the entire
investigation should die probably not
but you know it's also important to know
Papadopoulos was the counterintelligence
investigation began before the FISA
application on page but it was on
Papadopoulos so this is an important
point right so this is it's it's an
important point so again this is this is
all weird and somewhat confusing right
they've been surveilling they've been
surveilling the the members of the of
these Trump campaign Carter page had
been surveilled by the FISA back in 2014
there a lot of sketch characters working
for all of us but Papadopoulos was under
investigation first so well there are
serious questions to be raised about the
the warrant on Carter page I'm trying to
set out the timeline in my own head as
we go along here
Devon Nunez just confirmed the end of
the New York Times narrative the
Papadopoulos was actually under
investigation first and one of the
things that the the
investigation is covering here is is I
want to clarify and I want to backtrack
again I'm doing this all in real time so
the original FISA application that was
taken out against Connor page it's now
clear from this from this timeline that
that is not what actually launched the
investigation because paragraph five let
me reread that okay this is the the
paragraph five the page FISA application
also mentions information regarding
fellow Trump campaign adviser George
papadopolis the Papadopoulos information
triggered the opening of an FBI
counterintelligence investigation in
late 2016 by FBI agent Peter struck
what's interesting about that it sort of
buried in there and a little biased and
I had to read it twice because I'm
getting texts from from lawyers or
friends is that if the page fives a
application mentioned information
regarding Papadopoulos that means that
the investigation was already on
regarding Papadopoulos so doesn't kill
the entire Muller investigation what it
does do is call into question how the
FBI and the DOJ were pursuing that
investigation so that means that there
should be serious consequences inside
the FBI and the DOJ for their the
alacrity with which they sought to go
after Carter page but it doesn't
necessarily kill the entire
investigation so that may be the happy
medium that we are coming to here if
that is the case then that means that if
Trump starts firing people in the Muller
investigation that is probably a bad
move the so it's it's you know this is
it's not a nothing burger but it is also
not the end of the Muller investigation
okay that may be the the most the the
the that may be the best thing I can say
now Trump was asked about all he was
asked specifically about Rosen Stein and
in Trump being asked about Rosenstein
said that he may fire him basically
thank you very much
you you figured that one out okay so
he's saying that maybe he'll fire rosin
Stein
maybe you should fire Rosen Stein
possible should you fire Muller over
this again if the investigation
commenced before Carter page and there's
more to the investigation than just
Carter Page as I said before so you know
there's there's some dirty stuff here
but is it everything that is cracked up
to be originally on first reading know
if they've you're a little bit confused
that's okay I'm going to explain again
I'm gonna go back and backtrack I'm
gonna explain again in just a second
you're gonna have to come over to Daley
we're calm for all of that for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription to
Daley we're calm and that means you can
also be part of our mailbag so we're
doing our mailbag today which is a
tremendous unbelievable mail bet you'll
love it it is spectacular and you will
also get the rest of Michael motional
live dress to the Andrew Klavan show
live plus if you get the annual
subscription then you get this the very
finest in beverage vessels the leftist
tiers hot or cold tumbler and I'm going
to take a swig from that right now
because my goodness what a morning so I
check all of that out you just want to
listen later SoundCloud iTunes YouTube
subscribe there please leave us a review
we always appreciate we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
okay so the short summary you got to see
my entire thought process as it happened
right so here's the short summary of the
memo
Faiza application on Carter page may
have been gotten by ill Gaines Carl page
application is not the entirety of the
Trump Russia collusion investigation nor
was it the launching point of the Trump
Russian collusion investigation which
means is very hard for Trump to fire
Muller and just kill the investigation
outright or to say that this is the only
thing that was being investigated
however it does demonstrate FBI and DOJ
working with the Hillary campaign
presumably and acting in corrupt fashion
particularly with regard to Carter page
so is it a scandal yes is it a scandal
big enough to blow up the entire muddler
investigation of the Trump Russian
collusion investigation probably not
probably not okay so there you are there
is there is the the phone
there's the full-on understanding okay
so let's do a couple of things that I
like and then some things that I hate
and then we will get to the mailbag so
things that I like I think we need to
calm down Susan Bach so we've been doing
both pieces all week long this is a
piece that you'll know you may not
recognize that it's that it is Bach
because nobody knows music anymore but
it's box maybe most famous piece
you probably heard it when you were in
church at one point this is about the
Jesu joy of man's desiring
I'm not calm down now ah
okay now that we're all calm okay now we
can get back to a calm nice show the
world didn't implode everything's gonna
be okay hey listen would've been okay
anyway uh regardless of how this went
back to fact and so we'll have to see
how all this plays out but let's get to
another thing that I like so I have to
play you what I think is the funniest
thing that I have seen in a very long
time okay there is a a guy who attempted
to break into a car and a guy who I'm
friendly with Jon Kerley over at Cairo
radio in Seattle very nice guy good
sportscaster they recorded him doing a
play by play the sports play-by-play
just in time for the Super Bowl for a
guy trying to break into a car and it's
pretty spectacular can't break it that's
three four if you're counting at home
that's 14 blows against the window with
the mop now remember the dirty part of
the mop is underneath his arm he's got a
hat again he strikes the window and now
he comes down hard raining blows down
upon the window one two three and this
is just about tuckered him out he places
them up on top of a roof and now he
starts to think about whether or not he
wants to climb up he places his right
foot on top of the wall here he comes at
a ball oh my god somebody get some
salami and cream cheese and rubbing all
over his face he's unconscious on the
ground with the mob okay Sports is
fantastic I am going the Super Bowl this
weekend so I'm very pumped up about that
it's first Super Bowl and probably the
last Super Bowl I will everything it
should be it should be fun okay let's
see other things that I like so this is
something that you have to you have to
like because it's not something I like
as much as I feel just terrible for the
father here so well there's a father
who's three daughters were gymnasts in
the US gymnastics program and they were
abused by Larry Nance for this human
piece of garbage and the father in the
courtroom charged Larry Nasser and I
just wish I wish that the security had
not stopped him because Larry Nasser
deserves every bit of brutality that
this father can inflict on him no sir I
can't you know that I can't do that
that's not how our legal
[Music]
okay so you know obviously you wish that
this should be part of the justice
system I'm all in favor of changing the
law so that the the parents of the
victims of child molestation get to
brutalize the the Trott molesters that
seems to me completely just and I'm
entirely okay with it okay time for a
quick thing that that I hate and then
we'll get to the mailbag so the thing
that I hate today is politifact so
politifact is a left-wing fact-checking
organization how do I know that it's
left-wing because they don't even fact
check the people they use Pfeffer
fact-checking so yesterday the released
information that Alan Grayson a
representative from Florida who is a
complete nutjob I mean a complete and
utter nutjob thinks Ted Cruz was not
eligible to be President
compared the Tea Party to the KKK he's
just he's a complete crazy person he has
attacked a reporter I mean like here's
an actual Mille video of him attempting
to go after a reporter now people know
going forward that simply showing up to
a public event means that you come and
hassle me you're again in my face that
gives you the right to push me you
pushed me sir you pushed me no I was
standing there and you pushed no I'm
sorry I think what million well that's
right and that's a good thing I'll be
hand that over to the Capitol police my
friend is getting from the reporter
arrested assaulting you for a few
questions no no not for asked me these
questions for getting in my face and
being a fool and pushing me as I was
trying to be the severe sister why did
the grab swipe audacity is making these
allegations
I mean he's a crazy person Alan Grayson
so politifact hired this idiot to
actually be a fact checker for then he
was gonna be the voice of the people
they heard a Republican congressman is
anti Trump and they hired Alan Grayson
to be the fact checkers for politifact
and then they had to fire him later that
afternoon when it came out as everyone
who follows politics even minutely knows
that he is a complete nut bag
okay so just demonstrates the politifact
isn't all that it's cracked up to be
pretty pretty astonishing okay time for
the mailbag so let's do this thing okay
Patrick says hi then can you explain the
situation with the Pfizer scandal Devon
Nunez in the FBI so this time back to
the Russia probe if so help I hear a lot
about it in the news but the issue is
murky to me so we spent most of the show
explaining this but here is the brief
story okay the FISA scandal basically
here's the deal the suggestion well
Devon Nunez put out a four-page memo the
memo came out today we just read it in
its entirety the memo basically suggests
that a FISA warrant was gotten on a US
citizen Carter page was a member of the
Trump campaign and was gotten at the
behest of the Hillary campaign it was he
gotten at the behest of the Hillary
Clinton campaign working through fusion
GPS and that the DOJ and the FBI
basically took a piece of Oppo research
put together by Hillary Clinton and then
use that as a basis to surveil Trump now
the implication is that this is sort of
the the poisonous tree the root of the
poisonous tree and that should destroy
the entire mall or Russia and collusion
investigation that apparently is not
true the noonas memo includes sort of
buried in there the information that
suggests that the investigation predated
the Carter page FISA warrant issue so
two things can be true ones the five FBI
and DOJ could be corrupt the FBI and DOJ
could've been working with Hillary
Clinton on the Carter page thing and it
is also possible but the investigation
is more than just Carter page and that
this doesn't kill the investigation but
that's that's the really short story
here okay Christopher Martin says well
it is obvious the Democrats have painted
themselves into an ideological corner
with regard to the president do you see
an opportunity for them to seek common
ground with Republicans in Congress I
think it's highly unlikely because any
common ground they find with Republicans
in Congress will end up being common
ground with Trump they've obviously
decided they would rather not legalize
1.8 million illegal immigrants then even
conceive of making some sort of deal
with Trump so that's sort of an
astonishing political move on their part
because yeah Trump either is gonna pass
good proposals or he won't
he's unable to pass good proposals
because Democrats stymie it and he puts
forward a bunch of you know friendly
bipartisan proposals and Democrats just
keep pushing back it's not gonna reach
down to their benefit
JC says dear mr. Shapiro I'm a South
African citizen recently immigrated to
the United States because I like you
believe America is the greatest
experiment in human history my question
is regarding the latest Republican
immigration proposal especially as it
relates to chain migration since I like
you believe in limited government and
the people should rely on their family
friends and local churches for help how
does it make any sense to forbid people
from bringing their family with them the
current system demands the person
sponsoring their family member has to be
financially capable of supporting said
family member could we not simply create
a means by which we limit the amount of
government assisted immigrants can
obtain rather than simply banishing them
from coming at all sure I mean I'd be
very much in favor of that I mean I do
think that the idea of limiting
government assistance to immigrants
ensuring that they are culturally
assimilated then I'm fine with open
immigration I don't have a problem with
the number of people coming in I think
that a lot of people like Tom cotton and
Jeff Sessions have made the case that
hurts the country economically to bring
in new people who want to work I don't
think that's the case at all by any
stretch of the imagination Joshua asks
what do you think Bach or Mozart would
think of big band jazz you know hard to
hard to get in their heads I think they
would be confused by it well there's not
a lot can't appoint in big band jazz
they probably think that it was
relatively rudimentary because it is I
mean when you compared to classical
music big band jazz is relatively
rudimentary but that said I think that
they would enjoy the work of Gershwin
probably because Gershwin is is creative
and also has classical temperament I
enjoy big-band jazz by the way but it is
a simplified version of music I mean
it's a simplified form of classical
music I said whether they may have been
impressed by the emotion of big-band
jazz but they certainly would have been
impressed by the intellect and big-band
jazz even though I enjoyed Corey says
hello Ben it seems you're always busy
producing content is procrastination
something you've ever dealt with that if
so can you give advice for those that
currently struggling so I'm not by
nature a procrastinator I tend to think
I'm very good at delayed gratification
so I tend to think that if I get
something done now I won't have to deal
with it later but here's my suggestion
it's sort of the same as Dave Ramsey's
suggestion about that do the little
things first make a list of the things
that you want to get done and then take
the things that are easiest to do and
strike those off the list first so you
feel like you have momentum because you
start with a really big thing you're
gonna want to put that off because it's
too intimidating but if you knock all
the little things off your list you'll
actually get them done so that that's
the easiest way to avoid
procrastination Cody says habit my wife
and I are huge fans has evangelical
Christians we really appreciate your
stance on abortion
we're wondering what the likelihood of
roe v-- wade ever being repealed would
be and what it would take to do so well
takes five votes for roe v-- wade to be
repealed that would not in fact make
abortion illegal across the nation it
would just say that states have the
capacity to pass laws on abortion right
so that's the idea so the idea that that
roe v-- wade goes away and suddenly
abortions illegal across the country
that's not correct in California it
would stay illegal in New York it would
stay legal in Massachusetts too and stay
legal in Alabama it would suddenly
become illegal Emanuel says this week
you've been reviewing classical
composers and music are there modern
musical composers that you know or like
I don't I'll be honest with you I don't
know a lot of modern classical composers
the ones that I've heard like Philip
Glass and John gage are less than
impressive to me
I don't enjoy their music very much it
seems to me that most of the good
classical music is actually being
written for film at this point you know
if you listen to the scores of Elmer
Bernstein or Jerry Goldsmith or if you
listen to the scores of John Williams
then you're listening to some some
pretty solid classical music actually
just used in dramatic fashion more
romantic period certainly than classical
period music the guy can't remember the
name of the guy who wrote the score to
How to Train Your Dragon that's a great
score with some terrific music alright
Clayton says dear men's seeker of facts
destroyer of feelings I like that I've
been hearing a lot about Chelsea
Manning's attempt to run for Senate this
puzzles me because according to the
third section of the 14th amendment he
can't
the third section has barred a man named
Victor Berger from his congressional
seat for violating the Espionage Act the
self same accident Manning himself
committed is it it is worth noting that
Bergman was acquitted dude biases of the
judge on the trial against him lastly I
don't think the sentence commutation
would save him as the amendment states
that only Congress can absolve you fun
facts only two people have been absolved
Jefferson Davis and robert e lee can
this be used to block his run so off the
top of my head and my answer is no
simply because i believe that there are
other there are other considerations as
far as state considerations that come
into account not just the constitutional
issue you know so you know i want to do
a little bit more research on that
newsweek suggests at least that chelsea
manning is capable of running so the
reason for that apparently is that the
constitution allows you as citizens who
have a criminal record run for congress
but state laws can be different the only
qualifications to run for US senate is
you have to be 30 years old to have
citizenship in the u.s. for at least
nine years
live in the state at the time of the
election it does not state on their
website anyone who has a criminal record
can't run for US Senate so I wonder if
this other case Victor burger it was
barred by state law so I'd have to have
to check it out Daniel says I'm stuck
between two worlds I've been going to
school for music but I have a passion
for writing philosophy and history as
well how do i reconcile the artistic
with the political well I don't think
that you necessarily have to reconcile
them but what I would suggest is that
the same the same natural law that
undergirds a belief in reason as as
making possible the discovery of higher
truths makes possible the discovery of
better music so this is a view that was
held by Bach and Cuba held by Beethoven
how by Mozart held by Brahms the idea
there are natural laws to the human ear
natural laws to the human mind that
makes certain music better than other
music on an objective level I think that
is true and I think that is also true in
philosophy and history as well also I
think that you know one of the beautiful
things about the way that our current
free-market system works is that if you
became a very prominent musician
suddenly people actually care about your
opinion I mean released years they're
supposed to according to the Grammys
James says dear Ben what is your view on
gene altering I'm concerned that
technology like CRISPR is going to
expand beyond foundations of medicine
from treatment to intentional body
modifications examples of normal muscle
growth for sports or possibly genetic
sex changes or live extensions or
physical characteristics what is
altering your god-inspired vessel all
that my view is that if you are
correcting a flaw that is one thing if
you are simply trying to better yourself
through genetics that's another I think
that that carries serious risks yeah
essentially eugenics Brad says I want to
learn about it is real what book can I
read not just old history but modern as
well now the one that I recommend for
people is book by a guy named Jay Eli
bard he's the editor called myths and
facts about Israel it's 300 pages but
they're each kind of bite-sized
questions it's a bunch of questions that
are answered about Israel Benjamin
Netanyahu back in the 90s wrote a book
called the durable a durable peace which
is quite good about the history of
Israel and how modern Israel operates
today Colin says I'm a Christian
philosopher so I obviously interact a
lot with the question of God's existence
and the arguments for and against his
existence you mentioned his speech once
you found some of the atheist arguments
quite compelling if so which arguments
why and why then aren't you an atheist
and beyond that what convinces you that
God exists just being devil's advocate
so the argument for atheism is that
there is no free will we are just balls
of flesh wandering
through the universe I don't find that
completely implausible that's a
possibility I'm not gonna pretend that
atheism isn't a possibility I will
suggest that I find it not more
plausible than the explanation that we
have free will we are capable of
changing in our own lives
that our action is in our own hands that
we are endowed with reason that that
extends beyond just neuronal firing that
I think is a more compelling case so
what I'm suggesting is that belief in
God does not have to be certainty to be
probability and so I believe that God
exists and that he controls the universe
is involved in our lives
and that he is handed to us a set of
precepts that help guide our lives and
make better civilization one of the
reasons for that is almost utilitarian
which is that the only great
civilization in the history of the world
in my viewpoint is the judeo-christian
civilization springing from those
foundations but the Atheist argument
which is that basically everything
happened through accident I don't find
it supremely compelling but I find it at
least plausible I mean it's a plausible
the idea that the universe is eternal
that we've gone through a billion
iterations of the universe that
eventually we hit on the that eventually
we hit on the universe that we currently
live in and that just because it's
improbable that we exist in the way that
we do doesn't mean that it's really
improbably when you repeat the game a
bunch of times
Zack says - which of the arguments for
God's existence is your favorite the
ontological like Knowles the unmoved
mover argument of Aristotle and Aquinas
the moral argument of Conte well I would
suggest that the I find the the
Aristotelian Aquinas argument the best
on the ontological argument I don't find
quite as compelling the argument you
know the the ontological argument is
usually expressed as st. Anselm said
that if you can imagine God that God
therefore must exist that's the this
sort of very simplified and non correct
version for the unstructured ontological
argument now the Aquinas argument which
is that in the infinite regress of
causes has to terminate in a first cause
and unmoved mover or at least an
unnatural eyes day actualize er I find
that a compelling rational explanation
of why things exist the way that they do
and I also think that if you believe
that as contests I like the content
argument as well the content argument
suggesting that we have an innate moral
sense and that was placed by something
like God I think that that is I think
that's right but
the only argument that actually gets you
to a God who is perfect good and all
mowing is the Aquinas argument not
necessarily the content argument Henry
says hey Ben what was it like being on
South Jordan Peterson thoughts on him as
a person as an intellectual I really
like Jordan I mean I think that Jordan
is a very mild-mannered guy who is
constantly thinking and it's something
that I appreciate he's constantly asking
questions and learning I really like him
and there's a whole group of folks with
whom I may disagree on substantial
issues that I like personally because I
think that they are interested in asking
questions and like talking about facts
and first principles to me that's the
that's the mark of somebody who's
interesting to talk to somebody who
likes talking for his principles so for
example I've you know criticized Sam
Harris's views because I disagree with
him I really like Sam I think Sam is a
good guy Eric Weinstein is somebody who
I disagree with but I have fun talking
to him because we can talk for his
principles and examine each other's
thoughts and make them sharper I really
enjoy that I think Jordan is one of
those people Alexander says Ben you were
constantly ripping on different pop
songs which pop song or singer is your
guilty pleasure well I mean I don't
really have one as far as a pop song or
singer there was one song that came out
recently that the the name escapes me
that for some reason I find particularly
catchy I'll look it up and I'll play it
next week to humiliate well okay so that
one is actually catchy songs I praise
that on the show as a catchy song
there's also why I don't remember the
lyric to it I'll have to look it up but
it's it's it's playing through my head
right now it did a little bump um deadly
dun dun dun dun catchy song so there are
some of these songs that are catchy but
I don't remember who did them nor do I
care
Toby says Ben what is gonna happen in
the last season of Game of Thrones
what's gonna happen in the last season
of Game of Thrones that they're going to
all decide on a democracy that has led
by Tyrion after Danny dies she's gonna
be cast as the all-perfect all-knowing
all-wise person she's gonna end up dying
and then they're gonna have to come up
with a democracy we already know this
because they've hinted at it it's really
boring I'm shocked the last season they
had Tyrion openly hint that to Danny
like they're about to go into battle
he's like what if we formed a democracy
come on okay so like I like democracy
and all but this is a game of Thrones
okay it's not the game of destroying the
Thrones we're gonna break the chain
we're gonna break - well yes I
understand you're foreshadowing this for
seven seasons all right Taylor says dear
Ben my brother just graduated Marine
Corps boot camp and is now as an
infantry
he's an honorable Christian young man
who joined from love of country in the
country and the values she didn't
shrines
I think he's recently realized this
choice meant one day caused him to take
a life and he has expressed he doesn't
want to kill well I'll just say to those
who have the courage to serve but
struggle with taking another's life I
mean what I would suggest is that I mean
if you're joining the military and
you're joining a line of work that
involves possibly killing people that
that's a serious consideration you know
obviously I think that there are people
who need to be killed I think terrorists
need to be killed I think that there are
Isis members who need to die and I don't
think that the Bible suggests that the
word is do not murder it's right it's
it's not don't kill there are two
separate words is low-tier talk right
which means do not murder the word for
kill in Hebrew is Tahar oh this is it
would be low-tide rogue if they didn't
want you to kill Patrick says Haven I
figure you have a pretty negative view
of prostitution in pornography
give me a general sentiment that people
should generally be left alone how do we
balance the laws concerning these
activities and leaving people alone to
do what they will so public pornography
public displays of pornography I think
can be regulated because you're talking
and they're about things that affect the
community they have externalities
prostitution is is another thing that
affects public commerce I tend to be in
favor of legalization of prostitution
you know leaving aside the exploitation
of women which of course should be
illegal that said my feeling is that a
social board work is necessary and that
law is that if if law is the only
bulwark between you and the abyss then
law is not going to save you okay we
will be back here next to one more one
more
Kate says my fiance and I can't pick a
honeymoon location suggestions so the
places that I love Hawaii Hawaii is just
fantastic
and it's also relatively affordable if
you can afford it Italy is fantastic
honeymoon location Italy is just
phenomenal France is great you know I
love Israel as well I think is really
fantastic
but if you just want a relaxed place
you're just gonna go and lie back and
not have to rush around seeing things
then Hawaii is the place to be Hawaii's
just spectacular and I would suggest the
island of Maui I've been to most of the
islands at this point Maui is is I think
the nicest all right so we will be back
here next week with all of the fallout
from memo Gay 2018
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018